The Joe Rogan experience.
What is your perspective on the big bang D D D there's a lot of people's
views vary depending upon like what,
what the most recent theories are. Yeah.
But some people believe that the universe started with the big bang and some
people believe that it's always existed and there's,
it's a continuing cycle of big bangs, endless expansion,
and then ultimately contraction. And then it starts all over again.
And that there's infinite numbers of big bangs that are occurring through
multiverses, various universes, all over the world or all over the.
Right.
So I'm reading this book right now called the end of everything by a friend of
mine, Katie Mac wrote it. It's about the end of the universe.
And that's really cool. It talks about exactly what you're saying.
So there was a big bang. You can see it actually in the cosmic background,
radiation, there's this microwave and isotropy, it's like,
everything's not uniform. And you can see that it's like two or three degrees.
Calvin it's really cold. So the question is, does it, does it explode?
And then does it shrink the big crunch, you know, does it come back? And, um,
they think there's this stuff called dark energy. So does it continue expanding?
And she calls it heat decay or this other,
one's the big rip where it just keeps on expanding, accelerating,
and like even electrons can't everything just disintegrates into nothing.
Um, and no one knows what's going to happen, but the really cool thing,
I was just reading the chapter about as it expands super fast,
um, I forgot the name of it. It's Boltzmann's brain or something.
There's some weird thing where, because of quantum physics,
which is completely not understandable,
if you say you understand quantum mechanics, you don't, um,
things can just randomly appear. So if you're,
if the universe is going to be around for trillions of years, like in theory,
at some 0.2 trillion years from now,
Joe Rogan could just suddenly create itself out of nothing in the universe.
And you'd like, look around and go, wow, what's going on?
And then you'd disappear instantly because of quantum mechanics. So that's,
it's a really what, yeah, it's explain that again. So the,
the theory is you could have an entire universe just because of quantum
mechanics, which is, um, the Heisenberg uncertainty principle, right? You don't,
you can't know position and velocity.
You can only know one or the other and an extension of that. Again, man,
I'm just a fighter pilot. I'm not a physicist, but you can,
things can just suddenly appear somewhere. And so given enough time,
even though it's highly unlikely,
this water bottle could create itself out of nothing, just because of physics.
The quantum mechanics. I remember my, uh, teacher at the air force Academy.
We'll use the example of all of the electrons and protons and stuff could
suddenly move themselves. And you could just fall through the floor. Now,
the odds of that happening, it ain't going to happen for a trillion years,
but these weird things can happen. And so she, she uses this kind of cheeky,
funny example of, you know,
your brain could just suddenly create itself out of nothing.
And given enough time, the probability would be that.
So some people say the whole universe is just this temporary thing that created
itself. But I don't know, it was very disconcerting.
When you hear them talk about quantum mechanics.
That is, you know what I figured relativity.
And you started going, wait, what? Exactly?
Two things can exist simultaneously in different places.
And one of them could be in motion. The other one could be still,
and they're the same thing and they appear and disappear. And yeah.
What I mean now there's quantum computers. Yeah. That's weird. Yeah.
Do you understand that? No, I don't think no. I,
I spoke at a conference and I followed the quantum computing guy. So,
um, it's cool stuff. Right. You know,
I had guys like Sean Carroll tried to explain it to me on the podcast.
It just goes in one of my champions.
You and me both, man. I'm like I said, I'm a fighter. I love it.
It's cool to learn about it. But, um.
It, it does make things,
seem a lot more mystical than, um,
just the standard sort of Newtonian physics
perspective of life and gravity and matter,
and carbon based life forms. When you,
when you start getting into just listening to what they're talking about when
they're talking about quantum weirdness and entanglements and things in
superposition, and you're like, wait, w what is the world made of, right? Like,
can you get down to the smallest possible measurement
of life?
The S the smallest things that you can measure the world becomes magic yeah.
On the smallest scale, and also on the biggest scale. Right.
Well, that's the weirdest part about the universe is that I'm
inclined, especially as I get older.
And I think about things more to think that everything is kind of fractal
and what the universe is probably is,
it's probably a part of some other organism,
some immense organism that's in a universe.
That's impossible for us to comprehend the vastness of it. When, you know,
there was a thing they just did recently where they mapped out, uh, the human,
uh, they're talking about human brain cells and the universe.
And they were talking about the way the universe functions and the universe
functions the way it looks like if you do a scan of the universe, right? Like,
it looks far too similar to a human brain cell.
This is a talk I want to do, Joe. So I saw these patterns from space.
There's this one picture of a river in Indonesia. I took it.
It looks like arteries, like all these blood vessels coming out.
And I remember thinking there's all these patterns that repeat the seashells,
there's these spiral elliptical seashells, and then there's hurricanes. Yeah.
And then there's galaxies. And these,
these patterns repeat from the microscopic to the macroscopic. It's really cool.
It's amazing. Yeah. And I don't understand them all, but they, in images,
they they're really cool. Have you seen videos.
On fractals where they show you things like the Mandelbrot set and how the, the,
the closer you get to these fractals,
the same sort of pattern repeats itself over and over and over again.
And when people, it is one thing to comprehend it,
if someone's explaining it to you in a lecture, but as another thing now,
with the advent of CGI technology,
you can see these fractals be repeated over and over and over again. Right.
And the Mandelbrot set is a particularly interesting one because it's so
beautiful and weird. And, uh, each, each part of that,
as they go deeper in it, see if you can find a video on it.
Cause it's pretty bad Mandel brought, set fractal demonstration.
Um, I know it's on YouTube, but that these, these patterns,
if the universe really is a part of an atom, that's in a being right,
or a part of a cell that's in a being that exists in, uh, an, you know,
the idea of infinity too, right. We think of the universe as being massive.
It's 14 billion light. That's not infinite. Right. That's not even close. Right.
14 billion years is like nothing.
It's not infinite. No. At all. Um.
So this is the Mandelbrot set. Right?
And so what these artists have done is as they zoom in the Mandelbrot set,
repeats itself over and over and over and over again. And it just,
it becomes the same exact thing at the lowest possible
levels of, uh, of, of comprehension. Oh. Or of illustration.
They keep getting closer and closer to it. That's amazing. That's yeah.
I needed that. I was a math major in college and I learned about fractals,
but they didn't have videos back.
Right. But this video to sell this, this would blow you away. Right.
Because it shows it to you that in a way that appeals to the brain. Right.
And it's,
it's so hard for us to comprehend or to try to illustrate it ourselves.
This is the kind of that you see when you're on psychedelic drugs too.
This is another reason why it makes me worried the mushroom. Yeah. Yeah.
Like if you go on a super trip,
like a real trip where you can't come back for four or five hours,
this is the kind of that you'll see. And it makes you wonder, like,
are you looking at the,
the very fabric of the cosmos itself?
So I think there's a theory.
String theory is kind of popular for small stuff at what electrons are made out
of and in the smallest subatomic level. And if I remember right,
10 to the minus 33rd meters, which is pretty small,
but I think that's as small as you can get, like, there's a, there's a,
there is a smallest particle. You can't just keep on going infinitely smaller,
just like you can't go infinitely bigger because the universe is only so big.
So there it is bounded that can't happen forever. Um,
which is pretty well allegedly, but, you know, right. But you know,
10 years from now, everything we think we know is going to be disproven.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.